we have a big announcement to make on
the show the David Pakman show as you
know it is going to be ending in a few
weeks in the sense that producer Louis
is going to be departing from the
program uh now Louis this may come as a
shock to many in the audience we didn't
have an interview today specifically
because partially we want to uh discuss
this with you because I think it will be
both shocking uh
debilitating and exciting to different
people in the audience of course many
people don't want you to be part of the
show many people don't want me to even
be part of the show it's crazy people
want the David Pakman show knows that
we'll just don't want the show to exist
at all
right yet no devil that that's fair uh
so let's explore this louis uh give us
the backstory and i will allow you to
present why you will be leaving the
great city of boston uh and maybe that
classification is great is something
that is related to this story yes I
might not classify it that way but uh
city life is just is just not for me I
have determined and uh while I I enjoy
doing the show it's uh it is not for
show related reasons that I'm leaving
the show I just really don't want to be
anywhere near the city it's it's it
sounds like people aren't gonna believe
me when I say that but it's really that
simple talk a little bit about because
you are fair we've talked about sort of
the two big things that you're looking
for in your next place and the city part
is one of them and there's another and
this might be interesting insight into
Louis's psyche yeah okay well I mean III
don't want to live in uh in complete
isolation and be a hermit and be three
hours from the nearest restaurant okay
so I would like to be close to a a a
population center but not one the size
of Boston and that you compared to so
many of the population centers as they
call in this country Boston's pretty
small sure but still too big for me and
and so I would like to be somewhere
a bit more rural but still close to uh
at least a medium-sized city and what do
you consider medium cuz it's so it's all
perspective coming from New York City
for me Boston is small right feels very
small it's four miles across or whatever
at you know very very small so for your
perspective what would be like a
suitable size metro area to be near but
not in yeah I would say between a
hundred and fifty thousand and three
hundred fifty thousand people would be
suitable okay uh but not to live in to
live near to live near right right and
so I I don't want to deal with the the
noise the smells the traffic the uh uh
the the cement in concrete everywhere
and all of that stuff and I also really
don't want to deal with winter ah now
we're getting into part two yes part two
is I I really I really do not like
winter I am not designed to tolerate
winter well and is this because of your
Persian and Jewish uh ethnicity no
probably mostly because I'm I'm uh
really thin okay and uh whatever that
means I mean as a relates to winter and
and dealing with it um so there's all of
that and uh just the the the the city
life just not feeling it need a little
bit more room a little more green a
little more space and a little more
peace and quiet so big picture you would
be looking to be outside of an area
outside of a city that's no more than
three hundred thousand people in a part
of the country where and are you saying
where there is no winter or what would
be like the low winter temperature that
you would tolerate
I mean mild very mild winters would be
fine right and so I'm thinking uh that I
wouldn't be dealing with snowfall and
that uh temperatures wouldn't really be
dropping below freezing so 32 at the
coldest day sort of your baseline and
even that I don't really like but yeah
that would be uh I suppose that would be
acceptable if I'm not dealing with the
precipitation and all that right for
many people and I think this will be
sort of an eye opener when
we've explained to a few people off air
what's going on they say I'm genuinely
interested in this Louis because a lot
of people would decide where to live
based on things like proximity to family
how many people you know there and sort
of whether there's a specific job or
occupation that you would be
participating in but you've sort of
decided that the really important things
are uh climate and sort of our level of
urbanity for lack of a better term
uh well uh it's I know why people choose
to live why those decisions are
important to people why they decide to
live in a certain place like you
mentioned close to family uh employment
opportunities so on and so forth yeah
but that is not really like when I moved
to Boston
I kinda convinced myself that I'd like
it and I thought to myself yes well my
family's here and well my friends are
here and uh and yet this job it's great
I love it but none of that ended up
battery didn't and so uh and maybe not
everyone is the same as me but first I
would like to find a place where I know
I can enjoy living right and then the
friends the the work all of that stuff
that will happen do you at have any
concern and I asked this not
rhetorically and not implying anything I
say it with peace and love do you have
any concern that sometimes the grass can
seem greener on the other side uh the
grass is uh it the grass is greener in
other places yes uh I I lived in Austin
for two years and as many people know
and and this the the city stuff was
really getting to me there but despite
that I left about ten miles north of
downtown it was uh I mean I would take
that over Boston at any day and uh to be
perfectly honest I would take that over
Western Mass uh where I'm from any day
despite the city stuff that I'd have to
deal with in a place like Austin so we
have a number of different special uh
Louis tributes plan we have something
that our segment producer and interred
in turn John uh astutely called bistro
linguistics which is going to be airing
in over the next few weeks as Louis
transitions out and it is basically a
compilation of Louis's greatest
food-related moments and you know he's
had many of them on the show and we also
have John working on a really great
Louis highlight video he's literally
working on it as we speak uh I think I
can't see his screen but I'm sort of
counting on the fact that he is working
on that if you have any favorite Louis
moments that you would like included in
this video by all means let me know and
then I will make sure that that gets to
John and uh uh we will continue to
celebrate Louis's uh involvement in and
contributions to the David Pakman show
overtime and that there will be a lot of
uh compelling and and funny and
interesting moments for people and of
course the if I accidentally had a kid
I'd probably love the kid moment that is
a must on any compilation video uh yes
we we were considering putting that in
the bistro linguistics video even though
I had nothing to do with it just because
uh of how how fond David is of it yeah
uh so we have as you know we have Rachel
who's been participating on the show one
day a week she's going to be adding a
second day starting very very soon we
also have producer Jason Shepherd who
has been under the tutelage of Louis as
I like to say uh are you taking it all
in Jason I mean this is you've been
thrown into essentially a uh well I
don't know I don't know what you've been
thrown into possum into a into a chasm
yet but uh how do you feel about Louis's
uh prioritizations and decision and and
how does it all feel because you
recently moved back to the Boston area
yeah so I feel like we're we're almost
just like switching roles lives here
where I was on the west coast for the
last kind of eight years and I'd almost
recommend where I was this place called
Santa Barbara California seems like it
was almost made for you never never
warmer than 70 never colder than you
know 65 yeah
maybe snow one day every other year on
the mountains there so I'll throw those
that there but I feel I have some big
shoes to fill
trying to pick up everything that he's
putting down if you will and I feel like
I'm you know slowly getting it all but
yeah Louis
I think if I can speak for you and I
don't mean to Santa Barbara would be
great except I think it would be even
too urban and you hate California don't
you oh I don't I don't hate California I
I don't like LA uh-uh that's but
California is also very expensive and uh
also that's kind of a third thing right
you're looking for a place maybe where
cost of living is lower than on the
coasts so to speak on the on the North
East Coast and the west coast that would
be nice yes because um well yeah right
now it's just ridiculous here in Boston
and it's uh it's getting a lot worse and
I would like to avoid that I'm sure
Boston of course probably more expensive
in Santa Barbara but uh but California
overall is very expensive all right so
that is the big announcement we will be
taking everybody's feedback over the
next several weeks Luis will continue to
be here with us and we will uh continue
talking about it and I I know Luis that
there will be some people who will email
and we'll be absolutely devastated by
this decision of course we can
understand that there will be people who
will be absolutely thrilled by this
decision and of course we can expect
that and many people don't like you many
people don't like me yet they do watch
the show with regularity uh and there
will be many people who will assume that
this means I am the next person to
transition out of the David Pakman show
which of course doesn't really make
sense but I know that now that the
window has been open some people will
hope that I will soon be gone from my
own show and that's to be expected right
it is yes uh I'm very curious to see
what the responses will be and uh yeah
well just uh yeah have at it yeah hit me
like I am and with peace and love we
bring you this announcement we will take
a break and a lot more to talk about
neck